That's unified function call syntax. Uniform. Unicorn. Unicorn. Yeah, it should be called unicorn because we're probably never going to get it in C++. This is before your time in the committee, Connor, but that's exactly the joke. Oh, is it? Yeah. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 85, recorded on June 24, 2022. My name is Connor,
这就是统一函数调用语法。Uniform。Unicorn。独角兽。是的，它应该叫独角兽，因为我们在C++里大概永远也用不上它。康纳，这在你加入委员会之前就有了，但这就是那个笑话的精髓。哦，是吗？是的。欢迎收看ADSP播客，第85期，录制于2022年6月24日。我是康纳，
and today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue part two of our four-part interview with Tony Van Eerd. Here's another story I just told the other day at work. You would get bugs, right? You know, like I'm working on BlackBerry. We'd get a bug report that, you know, someone's typing and scrolling and there's the trackpad and it got confused about whether you were touching the screen or the trackpad or the keyboard because they're all so close together and stuff, right? And it's like, hey, can you like filter out the mistaken touches, right? Like if you're swiping the trackpad, you want to ignore the screen.
今天和我的联合主持布莱斯一起，我们继续与托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd）四部分访谈的第二部分。这里有另一个我前几天在工作时刚讲过的事。你会遇到Bug，对吧？你知道的，比如我在黑莓工作。我们会收到一个Bug报告，说，你知道的，有人在打字和滚动，那里有触控板，它搞不清你到底是在摸屏幕、触控板还是键盘，因为它们靠得太近了之类的，对吧？然后就像是，嘿，你们能过滤掉那些误触吗？对吧？就像你在刷触控板时，你想忽略屏幕。
You didn't mean to touch the screen. It was just too close to the trackpad, right? Which of course I had told them when they were making the phone that they put the trackpad too close to the screen. But anyhow, it's like fix it in software, right? So you get these bug reports like that. And the bug is called
你并不是故意去碰屏幕的。它只是离触控板太近了，对吧？当然，我在他们做手机的时候就告诉过他们，他们把触控板放得离屏幕太近了。不过不管怎样，就像是在软件里修复它，对吧？所以你会收到像这样的Bug报告。而这个Bug被命名为
a mike l bug because it's not someone complaining it's mike l complaining that he was he was scrolling his trackpad in it and he got screen input accidentally right and um so those were like obviously high priority bugs because it's oh it's a mike l bug you got to fix it right away and my manager would take that part out of the bug. If it said Mike L bug in there, which everyone just knew what that meant, he would just remove it and leave a comment saying, remove superfluous information. Because my manager was just like, I don't care whose bug it is. It's either important or it's not important. And we're just like, man, you're just trying to get yourself fired, right? But he would do that
一个迈克尔Bug（mike l bug），因为这不是别人的抱怨，而是迈克尔在抱怨他在滚动触控板时意外触发了屏幕输入，对吧？然后呢，这些显然是高优先级Bug，因为“哦，这是一个迈克尔Bug，你必须马上修复它”。而我的经理会把Bug里的那部分拿掉。如果里面写了“迈克尔Bug”，大家都知道这意味着什么，他就会直接删掉，并留下一条评论说：删除多余信息。因为我的经理就是那种人，我不在乎这是谁的Bug。它要么重要，要么不重要。而我们当时就觉得，天哪，你这是在自找炒鱿鱼，对吧？但他就会这么做。
um the other part of that story is that every now and then i would be like okay i need to know was he scrolling up because he touched the trackpad and then the screen or was he like scrolling down he touched the screen then the trackpad because you know you're going to handle that differently it's easy to say it's easy when you touch the screen, you can say, well, did you just touch the trackpad like this many microseconds ago? Because I'll ignore the screen touch, right? But if you go the other way and you touch the screen and then the trackpad,
嗯，这个故事的另一部分是，每隔一段时间我就会想：好吧，我需要知道他是因为先碰了触控板然后碰了屏幕才向上滚动的，还是说他是向下滚动时先碰了屏幕然后碰了触控板？因为你知道，你得用不同的方式处理它。说起来容易，当你碰屏幕时很简单，你可以说，“好吧，你刚才是在多少微秒前碰的触控板吗？因为我会忽略屏幕触摸”，对吧？但如果你反过来，先碰了屏幕然后碰了触控板，
am I going to delay every screen input to say, well, let me wait to see if you touch the trackpad, right? Yeah. I think I ended up actually with, there's a region at the bottom of the screen where I do delay the touch input because it's like, well,
我是不是要延迟每一个屏幕输入来说，“好吧，等一下，看看你有没有碰触控板”，对吧？是的。我想我最后实际做出来的效果是，屏幕底部有一个区域，我在那里确实延迟了触摸输入，因为这就像是，嗯，
wait and see if you touch the track bed. But anyhow, I needed to know which, what, you know, it's like someone go ask Mike L what was going, like, give me more information.
等待并看看你有没有碰触控板。不过无论如何，我需要知道到底是哪个……你知道的，就像是有人去问问迈克尔到底是怎么回事，给我更多信息。
And the people that, because he's not obviously not logging his own bug, right? Someone else logs the bug for him in this, into the system. You ask that person, it's like, I need more information.
而那些人——因为他显然没有自己去提Bug，对吧？其他人帮他在系统中提交了这个Bug。你去问那个人，就像是：我需要更多信息。
They're like, oh, yeah, we'll talk to Mike and we'll come back to you. And they never get back to you because they don't talk to him because they're afraid to because he's the big bad boss. And so finally one day, every company has their all hands and all that kind of stuff. So I went to one of the all hands. I waited to the end. Mike Ells does his stalking.
他们就会说：“哦，行，我们会跟迈克尔谈谈，然后再回复你。”然后他们就再也没有回复过你，因为他们根本不敢跟他谈，因为他是那个可怕的大老板。所以最后有一天，每个公司都有全员大会（all hands）之类的活动。于是我去了其中一次全员大会。我一直等到最后。迈克尔·埃尔斯（Mike Ells）做完他的演讲，
I walked up to him at the end. said hey i got a bug i need to know like tell me tell me i need more information he's like oh yeah sure no problem blah blah blah we talked about this bug for five minutes and i told him i said look i've asked for this information no one will give it to me and he's like just come to my office just come come find me. And I'm like, excellent. I am now like firsthand, you know, first name basis with Mike. Just, hey, buddy, Mike. You know, just walk in when he's got a big meeting with somebody. Say, Mike, I just got to, everybody stop for a second.
我在最后朝他走去。说：“嘿，我有一个Bug，我需要知道……告诉我，告诉我，我需要更多信息。”他说：“哦，没问题，巴拉巴拉……”我们讨论了这个Bug五分钟，我告诉他：“听着，我一直在索要这些信息，但没人肯给我。”他却说：“直接来我办公室找我，直接来找我。”而我想：太棒了。我现在可以说是和迈克尔直呼其名了，你知道的。只要说：“嘿，老兄，迈克。”你知道的，当他和某人在开大会时直接走进去。说：“迈克，我有个问题要问你，大家停一下。”
I got a quick question for Mike here. He's my guy, my guy Mike, you know. I'm important. Yeah. And then I left the company. So I didn't actually get to use my power i don't think it was right before i left and for those of you that are extremely confused on why uh tony was talking about a trackpad on a cell phone uh i will link a i will link a photo of i'm not sure i had a
“我有个关于迈克的小问题。”他是我的铁哥们，我的好兄弟迈克，你知道的。我很重要。对。然后我就从公司离职了。所以我其实没能用上我的超能力。我觉得那就在我离职前不久。对于你们当中极其困惑为什么托尼要在手机上谈论触控板的人，我会放一个链接——我不太确定，我当时用的是
blackberry bold i think it had one of those trackpads yeah you had a blackberry he's canadian we give every canadian gets one when they're when they're born yeah when you when you graduate high school you got one i had a flip phone or slider phone when i graduated when i was in high school and then i used that into university but as soon as i had my first co-op at manulife in toronto i thought to myself well i'm i'm joining the world. I'll be ostracized if I show up without a BlackBerry. So I bought a BlackBerry Bold. Wait, wait. You had an iPhone.
黑莓Bold（BlackBerry Bold），我觉得它就有那种触控板。对，你用过黑莓。他是加拿大人，我们给每个加拿大人在出生时都发一个，对，当你们高中毕业时就能拿一个。我高中毕业时拿的是翻盖手机或滑盖手机，然后我一直用到上大学。但一到我在多伦多的宏利金融（Manulife）进行第一次实习时，我就心想：好吧，我正在融入这个世界。如果我没有带着黑莓手机出现，我会被孤立的。所以我买了一部黑莓Bold。等等，等等。你以前有iPhone。
I did not have an iPhone. I had one of those flip phones or slider phones. Oh, okay. Gotcha, gotcha, gotcha. There really is. Anyone who's played NHL video games, NHL 2K, even like 2K14, 2K15, I don't know when it stopped, but there's like the trading general manager mode where you can trade players
我没有iPhone。我用的是那些翻盖手机或滑盖手机。哦，好吧。明白了，明白了。确实有这回事。任何玩过NHL（北美职业冰球联赛）电子游戏的人，NHL 2K，甚至像2K14、2K15——我不知道它是什么时候停的——但里面有一个叫“总经理交易模式”的东西，你可以在里面与其他球队
with other teams and stuff. It shows a picture of a BlackBerry phone as like, hey, you're getting a call from you're getting a call from, you know, Vancouver Canucks. They want to make a trade. And it shows a BlackBerry phone. And I'm sure BlackBerry paid to get this advertising built in.
交易球员等等。它会显示一张黑莓手机的图片，就好像是：嘿，你接到了电话，你接到了来自温哥华加人队（Vancouver Canucks）的电话。他们想要做个交易。屏幕上显示的就是一部黑莓手机。我敢肯定黑莓花钱把这个广告植入进去了。
But it was also true. That was what it would be like to be a manager. Every manager had a BlackBerry. There's no doubt. Every, you know, GM in the NHL and every sport was carrying a BlackBerry so that they could do their stuff, right? Yeah.
但这也很真实。当一个经理就是这种感觉。每个经理都有一部黑莓手机。毫无疑问。NHL和各个体育联盟里的每个总经理都随身带着黑莓，这样他们才能处理工作，对吧？
BBM was like kind of, not really like Messenger, but it was like you could only message people that had BBM, right? So like it was this, it was like, you know, I'm not sure if it was before Facebook or whatever, but it was tapping into the whole, you know, same thing with Bloomberg. You know, you can't message people. I think that's changed, but at one point in time,
BBM有点像，不完全像Messenger，但它是这样的：你只能给拥有BBM的人发消息，对吧？所以它就像是……我不知道这是否在Facebook之前什么的，但它融入了整个……彭博终端（Bloomberg）也是一样。你知道的，你不能给别人发消息。我想现在这已经变了，但在某个特定的时间点，
people on Wall Street, like you were outside of Wall Street if you didn't have a Bloomberg. Yeah, yeah. It's the same thing. It's a critical mass. everyone's there because everyone's there um yeah everyone had bbm and then or or well or like the you know the the green bubble versus the the blue bubble on iMessage you know are you are you another trusted iphone user or are you the other you know uh chandler if he ever listens to this is
华尔街的人——如果你没有彭博终端，你就算不上是华尔街的人。对，对。情况是一样的。这就是临界规模。每个人都在那儿，因为每个人都在那儿。嗯，每个人都有BBM，然后或者说——或者就像iMessage上的绿气泡与蓝气泡的区别一样，你知道的，你究竟是另一个受信任的iPhone用户，还是另外一种……钱德勒（Chandler）如果他听到这个的话，
gonna like yeah just tell him now chandler just 10 seconds you got to cover your ears because i'm going to say the word patent but um i think blackberry has a patent on speech bubbles in like i message and stuff like that like and gary classen the guy who wrote BBM. And so every phone in the world, you know, does speech bubbles. And I don't know, you know, it's corporate, you know, patents, right? The way, you know, they, no one sues anyone unless everyone sues everybody. And I don't know. Yeah. It's the cold war.
一定会——对，现在就告诉他，钱德勒，给你10秒钟捂住耳朵，因为我要说“专利”这个词了。不过……我觉得黑莓在iMessage这类的语音气泡上拥有专利，你知道的。就像加里·克拉森（Gary Klassen），那个编写了BBM的人。所以世界上每部手机，你知道的，都有语音气泡。我不知道，你知道的，这就是企业专利，对吧？这种方式……没人会起诉任何人，除非所有人都起诉所有人。我不知道。是的，这就是冷战。
So here's the thing. Back to the patent story. BlackBerry, when I was there, had 40,000 patents. Right? Wow. 40,000 mobile, you know, in a good industry patents. Right? And then someone sat down.
所以事情是这样的。回到专利的故事。黑莓在我还在那儿的时候，拥有4万项专利。对吧？哇。4万项移动行业的专利。对吧？然后有人坐下来。
Like, how do you figure out how much that's worth? Do you look at all 40,000 patents? No. You do a sampling, right? You sample some number of patents and you look at them and say, well, this one's worth this much money. This one's worth this much money. You make some kind of guess at how much this patent is worth. And then you average it out. And you say, well, every patent here in this portfolio is worth about $100,000. And so the whole patent portfolio is worth $4 billion.
就像，你怎么弄清楚这值多少钱？你会去看所有4万项专利吗？不会。你会做抽样，对吧？你抽取一定数量的专利，看着它们并说：“嗯，这个值这么多钱。这个值这么多钱。”你对这个专利值多少钱做出某种猜测。然后你算出平均值。你会说：“嗯，这个组合里的每一个专利大约价值10万美元。”所以整个专利组合价值40亿美元。
So like BlackBerry, even if they did nothing else was worth $4 billion because they're sitting on $4 billion worth of patents, right? But that also means that if I write another patent, it's worth $100,000. It doesn't matter if it's good or bad, right? Because as long as it's a patent, it goes into the pool of well on average they're worth a hundred thousand dollars so every patent i wrote is another hundred thousand dollars on their books so i'm just like i'll just how many you want do you want you want 10 patents i'll write 10 i wrote patents for like um uh uh the the the watch right like you when the when the apple watch came out i'm like how do you you know and i won't get into these it's okay chandler i won't get into these the watch, right? Like when the Apple Watch came out,
所以黑莓，即使他们什么都不做，也价值40亿美元，因为他们坐拥价值40亿美元的专利，对吧？但这同时也意味着，如果我再写一个专利，它就值10万美元。它到底是好是坏并不重要，对吧？因为只要它是一个专利，它就会进入“平均价值10万美元”的专利池中，所以我写的每一个专利都会给他们的账面上增加10万美元。所以我当时就觉得：你们想要多少？你们要10个专利？我写10个。我写过关于……嗯……嗯……手表的专利，对吧？当苹果手表（Apple Watch）出来的时候，我在想：你怎么去……我不打算深入谈这些，没关系，钱德勒，我不会深入谈这些手表，对吧？就像苹果手表出来的时候，
I'm like, how do you, you know, and I won't get into these. It's okay, Chandler. I won't get into these patents. But like, how do you input text on a watch? It would be really hard, right? Because it's like a small surface. But if you really want to input text on a phone,
我在想：你怎么……我不打算深入谈这些，没关系，钱德勒，我不会深入谈这些专利。但是，比如，你如何在手表上输入文本？这会很难，对吧？因为它是一个很小的表面。但是，如果你真的想在手机上输入文本，
on a watch, I thought up 10 ways of doing it. And so I wrote them all down, right? And it doesn't matter if BlackBerry would ever implement those patents I wrote them down and they send them off and some of them get accepted as patents and some don't
在手表上输入文本，我想出了10种方法。所以我把它们都写下来了，对吧？黑莓是否会实现这些专利并不重要，我把它们写下来，然后把它们发出去，有些被接受成为专利，有些则没有，
and then they give me money that's what I did I was like man I can make more money by sitting here in an afternoon writing patents it's just like how at NVIDIA they give me I was like, man, I can make more money by sitting here in an afternoon writing patents. It's just like how at NVIDIA, they give me a referral bonus every time I recruit somebody. And I could just turn that into a full-time job.
然后他们会给我钱。这就是我当时做的。我就像：天哪，我只要在这里坐一个下午写专利就能赚更多钱。这就像在英伟达（Nvidia）一样，我当时就想：天哪，我只要在这里坐一个下午写专利就能赚更多钱。就像在英伟达，每次我招募一个人，他们就会给我一笔推荐奖金。我甚至可以把这变成一份全职工作。
I have a whole system. I have a whole system i have a whole system you know uh john lakos who tried to tried to tried to recruit me to be a recruiter after after he gave up recruiting me um he was just like can you find me stuff because he said like he's like the amount that they would pay a recruiter for finding somebody in new york? Is like a huge portion of the person's salary. And he's like, I will give you the same percentage if you find me people. And I can still stay in. Because every time he tried to recruit me, I'm just like, I don't want to move from Canada. I don't want to live.
我有一整套系统。我有一整套系统。约翰·拉科斯（John Lakos）曾试图——试图——试图招募我去当招聘人员，在他放弃招募我之后——他只是问：“你能帮我找些人吗？”因为他说，他愿意付给招聘人员在纽约找一个人的佣金，相当于那个人薪水很大的一部分。他说：“如果你帮我找人，我也给你同样的百分比。”而且我还可以继续留在……因为每次他试图招募我时，我都说：“我不想离开加拿大。我不想去住……”
I mean, New York's great. I just don't want to live there. And finally, he gave up trying to recruit me. But he's like, well, find other people. And I was like, I could probably make more money recruiting people for LACOS than programming on my own. Cause like I'm getting a percentage of some New York salary, but I'm living in Canada. And then I was like, except for, I don't want to be a recruiter. So screw that but every now and then i'll get a co-op student which for you non-canadians is intern i'll get an intern who i know doesn't want to work for me and i'm like hey do you want to work in new york because man i can set you up i also just tweeted one from one of my interns i'm like who wants my intern she wants to work at like apple and then olivier's like send her my way so see it's i i've always terrible nepotism right there if i didn't want to work in engineering anymore i could go start like i couldn't do a
我是说，纽约挺好的。我只是不想住在那里。最后，他放弃招募我了。但他转而说：“好吧，去帮我找别的人。”我就想：我帮拉科斯招人赚的钱，可能比我自己写代码赚的还多。因为我拿的是纽约薪水的百分比，但我住在加拿大。然后我就想：除了我不想当招聘人员之外……所以去他的吧。但每隔一段时间，我就会带一个“Co-op”学生——对于你们非加拿大人来说就是实习生——我会带一个我明知不想为我工作的实习生，然后对他说：“嘿，你想去纽约工作吗？因为老兄，我能帮你安排。”我还刚在推特上转发了一个我实习生的动态，我说：“谁想要我的实习生？她想去苹果（Apple）工作。”然后奥利维耶（Olivier）就说：“把她送我这儿来。”所以你看，这就是赤裸裸的裙带关系。如果我不想再从事工程工作了，我可以去开一家——我其实开不了初创公司，我没有什么好的初创公司点子——但我绝对可以开一家招聘公司，而且一定会大获成功。
startup i don't have any good startup ideas but i could i could definitely start a recruiting company so and it would be a killer so this this is the same thing right like so gary and i left blackberry all right pause pause pause let's just do some filling in here because I've realized we're doing like, what do you call it? Like inside shop talk. So Chandler works at Google. Actually, no. Our listeners know because we've had Chandler on. Olivier.
所以，这其实是一回事，对吧？我和加里离开黑莓……好吧，暂停，暂停，暂停。让我们来做点补充说明，因为我意识到我们一直在进行所谓的……你们叫什么来着？行话内幕。所以钱德勒在谷歌（Google）工作。其实，没有。我们的听众知道，因为我们请过钱德勒上节目。奥利维耶。
Listeners who've listened to every episode. Yeah. Everyone knows Chandler, anyhow. If you're in the C++ community. I mean, we're slowly becoming predominantly C++, but historically we would talk about other languages at times. Should we be talking about arrays? Sorry.
听过每一期节目的听众。是的，无论如何，每个人都知道钱德勒。如果你在C++社群里的话。我的意思是，我们正在慢慢变成一个以C++为主的播客，但历史上我们有时也会谈论其他语言。我们应该谈论数组吗？抱歉。
No, don't worry. But so Olivier, formerly at NVIDIA, now at Apple, and is from Quebec, Canada. Lakos refers to John Lakos. He works at Bloomberg in New York. Previously, are we allowed to mention that? The other well-known C++ person that is no longer at Bloomberg?
不，别担心。但是，奥利维耶，曾在英伟达，现在在苹果，来自加拿大魁北克。拉科斯指的是约翰·拉科斯。他在纽约的彭博社工作。在此之前——我们被允许提这个吗？那个不再在彭博社的另一位知名的C++人物？
I don't know which one you're talking about. Is that public knowledge? Oh, yeah. We can say that? Yeah, so David Sankal used to work at Bloomberg, but now is at Adobe. Yeah. So right now it's NVIDIA versus Adobe.
我不知道你在说哪一个。那是公开信息吗？哦，是的。我们可以说吗？是的，所以大卫·桑卡尔（David Sankal）以前在彭博社工作，但现在在Adobe。对。所以现在是英伟达对阵Adobe。
I'm not sure which one's Marvel and which one's DC, but we're just collecting, you know. Whoa, whoa, whoa. That's a bit of an exaggeration. NVIDIA has hired a lot more people than Adobe. Adobe's hired like one or two. Okay, so Adobe can be DC. I apologize, Sean, if you're listening.
我不知道哪个是漫威（Marvel），哪个是DC，但我们只是在集齐……哇，哇，哇。这有点夸张了。英伟达雇的人可比Adobe多得多。Adobe大概只雇了一两个。好吧，那Adobe可以是DC。肖恩，如果你在听的话，我向你道歉。
Maybe he doesn't watch any superhero movies, so he doesn't know the difference. But they've got some, like, they might not have the the quantity but they've got quality right i got quality too they've got they've got sean parent i got andre that's true all right all right i got it i got eric all right wait wait dave abraham's eric okay we're tie i think we're still tie darn it all right but then on top of that i got a lot of other yeah but then there's you so that's like a down like they they also have sean we don't have a sean yeah we had we said we i mean we had olivier but now olivier see i could have put you over the edge yeah all right there was like there was this one week
也许他不看任何超级英雄电影，所以他不知道区别。但他们有一些……比如说，他们可能没有数量上的优势，但他们有质量，对吧？我也有质量。他们有肖恩·帕朗（Sean Parent），我有安德烈（Andre）。确实如此。好吧，好吧，我有这个，我有那个。我有埃里克（Eric）。等等，等等，还有戴夫·亚伯拉罕（Dave Abrahams）、埃里克……好吧，我们打平了。我觉得我们还是打平了。气死我了。好吧，但除此之外，我还拥有很多其他的……是的，但还有你，所以这就有点像拉低了水平。他们也有肖恩，我们可没有肖恩。是的，我们有——我的意思是，我们以前有奥利维耶，但现在奥利维耶……看，我本来可以把你们比下去的。是的，好吧，有那么一个星期，
period where before olivier left when andre had just joined and that was that was the peak peak c++ at nvidia anyways i interrupted because you said when me and gary and i was like all right i don't know who gary is so we're going to update people, and now you can tell me who Gary is. Gary, I mentioned Gary. It's Gary Klassen, the guy who wrote BBM. Oh, right, right, right. Okay. By the way, so Gary works at Google now.
在奥利维耶离开之前，安德烈刚刚加入，那是英伟达C++的巅峰时期。无论如何，我打断了你，因为你刚才说“我和加里”，而我当时想：好吧，我不知道加里是谁，所以我们得给听众更新一下信息，现在你可以告诉我加里是谁了。加里，我刚才提到加里了。就是加里·克拉森，那个写了BBM的人。哦，对，对，对。好吧。顺便说一下，加里现在在谷歌工作。
Works at Google in Waterloo. Gary is the most energetic person I've ever met in my life. He's the most upbeat energetic like for the first two or three years i worked with him i'm like i don't believe this person i'm just like there's not it's not possible to be this upbeat and energetic and positive and but he just is that's just how he is he's still that way i've known him for like 10 years yeah he is yeah um interesting yeah he's just awesome anyhow um uh he left blackberry and i left backberry like near the same time but not at the same time and uh we ended up working together here at christy and we were both sitting here at christy and i was like gary you left blackberry
在滑铁卢的谷歌工作。加里是我一生中见过的最有活力的人。他总是那么乐观、充满活力……在我跟他共事的前两三年里，我心想：我真不敢相信这个人。我就觉得，一个人不可能这么乐观、充满活力和积极向上，但他就是这样，他一直都是这样。我认识他大概有10年了。是的，他确实是。嗯，有趣，是的，他太棒了。不管怎样……他离开黑莓和我离开黑莓的时间差不多，但又不是同一时间，然后我们最后一起在克里斯蒂（Christie）工作。我们俩当时都坐在克里斯蒂，我就说：“加里，你离开了黑莓。”至少在本地，他被称为发明了BBM的人。
and at least in this area he is known as you know the guy who invented bbm and in this area, he is known as the guy who invented BBM. And in this area, BBM is still a big deal, right? Because BlackBerry was a big deal. I was like, Gary, we could have started a startup with just your name. Just be like, Gary Klassen's doing a startup. Just like one of these, any, think of all the people, like if Sean Parent went and said he's going to do a startup, right? People would throw money at him.
在本地，他被称为发明了BBM的人。而在本地，BBM仍然是一件大事，对吧？因为黑莓曾经是一件大事。我就说：“加里，我们本可以只凭你的名字就创办一家初创公司。只要说：加里·克拉森正在创办一家初创公司。”就像这些人中的任何一个……想想看，如果肖恩·帕朗说他要创办一家初创公司，对吧？人们会把钱砸向他。
This is just because he's Sean. And Gary would definitely we could and i was like gary we'll think of something but we could just do a startup and then later from a patent writing machine yeah we'll figure out what we're going to do later you will patent you will patent a process for developing patents but anybody ever thought about that? Oh, for sure. That's probably a good idea. I mean, you could probably now get, oh, I've got so many sad, scary things that popped in my head there.
这只是因为他是肖恩。加里也绝对……我们可以……我当时说：“加里，我们会想出点什么的，但我们大不了先开一家初创公司，然后再变成一个专利制造机。”是的，我们会弄清楚我们以后要做什么。你将为一个开发专利的过程申请专利。有人想过这个吗？哦，当然。这大概是个好主意。我的意思是，你现在大概可以……哦，我脑子里突然冒出了好多悲伤、可怕的想法。
One is that you could get an AI now to write patents for you, probably, right? Just pump out some patent crap. And then, of course, you patent that AI. Yeah. So, you know know everyone's talking about the ai that could be sentient but not really um and it's like yeah it can't be sentient but how long before that ai is used as a twitter bot that you can't tell anymore that it's a twitter
一个想法是，你现在大概可以找一个AI来为你写专利，对吧？只要狂吐出一堆专利垃圾就行了。然后，当然，你给那个AI申请专利。是的。所以，你知道的，每个人都在谈论那个可能具有感知能力但其实又没有的AI，对吧？然后就像是：是的，它不可能有感知能力，但距离那个AI被用作Twitter机器人（Twitter bot）还有多久？到时候你再也分辨不出它到底是不是一个Twitter机器人了，
bot right because that's where we're at and And it's going to get really, really hard for, for Twitter people to figure out, Oh, this is a bot. That's just, you know, spreading information. And this is a real person.
对吧？因为这就是我们目前所处的情况。而且对于Twitter用户来说，要弄清楚“哦，这是一个散布信息的机器人”还是“这是一个真人”，将变得越来越难、越来越难。
Cause right now it's still, you know, you can do it with the computer to figure out, you know, bots sort of, but these, you know, AI things are getting way too good at sounding like a real thing.
因为现在……你仍然可以通过计算机大致分辨出哪些是机器人，但是这些……你知道的，AI东西在听起来像个真人这方面变得太厉害了。
Kind of scary. Anyhow, don't want to put that idea out there for those. You don't want to. Okay, good. We'll make sure that we get it. No one listens to this. That is true. Not as many people as CPP cast, that's for sure.
有点吓人。不管怎样，不想把这个想法透露给那些人。你不想这么做。好吧，很好。我们会确保我们……没人听这个播客。这倒也是。肯定没有CPP Cast那么多听众，那是肯定的。
We'll get there. we'll get there we'll get there we may not have quality but we have consistency I mean they had both so what are you there goes my video so speaking of we haven't even talked about our incoming party
我们会做到的，我们会做到的，我们会做到的。我们可能没有质量，但我们有持之以恒的精神。我的意思是，他们两样都有，所以你……我的视频挂了。所以说到这里，我们甚至还没聊我们的即将到来的派对。
yeah party i mean they're calling it a conference but we'll call it what it is it's a party yep it's it's a week it's a week-long birthday party for me oh yes that's it's been a while since you brought that up i've uh i forgot i shame on me for forgetting how could you possibly have forgotten i've sent you i sent you a calendar invite this week for the bryce birthday i'm sure he doesn't have to worry about forgetting uh and sure he will be reminded even i don't think that was this week i think that was previously but so you're you're speaking yeah you're not only you're going to be there you're going to be speaking yeah what uh give us a little give us a little give the listener and potentially the listener slash attendee a preview of uh what to expect uh i'm going to talk
对，派对。我的意思是，他们把它叫作大会（conference），但我们要实话实说，它就是一个派对。没错。这是一周的……这是一场为期一周的我的生日派对。哦，是的。距你上次提起这个已经过去一段时间了。我……我居然忘了，真该死，我怎么能忘呢。我给你发了……我这周给你发了一个关于布莱斯生日的日历邀请。我相信他不用担心会忘记，而且肯定会有人提醒他。我觉得那不是这周的，那是以前的。所以你要去演讲，对吧？你不仅会去，你还要在上面演讲。对，给我们……给听众和潜在的听众兼与会者剧透一点……期待点什么？我要讲
about functions so um here's the thing every time for the last like three or multiple years now every since sean gave his first talk at boost con um which was like the first boost contact of boost con um there's this whole thing of like pushing value, you know, what I like to call value-oriented programming instead of object-oriented programming, right? Which, whatever that means, but like Sean talks about it, Dave Abrahams talks about it, and it's really hard to actually, you know,
关于函数的内容。所以，事情是这样的。过去几年里——好几年了，自从肖恩在BoostCon上发表他的第一次演讲以来——那是BoostCon的第一次BoostCon演讲——一直有一种推动“值”的趋势，你知道的，我喜欢称之为面向值编程（value-oriented programming），而不是面向对象编程（object-oriented programming），对吧？不管这意味着什么，但肖恩谈过它，戴夫·阿布拉汉姆也谈过它，而要真正去描述它其实非常困难。
describe it and everything. So I'm constantly trying to, I keep telling myself, like, let's do a talk actually describe it and everything. So I'm constantly trying to, I keep telling myself, let's do a talk on value-oriented programming. And we'll just explain to people what value-oriented programming is. And then more importantly, what's the value in value-oriented programming? And then I'm like, whenever I start doing that, all I end up talking about is functions. So I'm like, screw values. I'm not going to talk about value oriented programming
所以我一直在尝试……我总是告诉自己：让我们做一场关于面向值编程的演讲吧。我们只要向人们解释什么是面向值编程。然后更重要的是，面向值编程的价值在哪里？然后我就发现，每当我开始这样做时，我最终谈论的全部都是函数。所以我心想：去他的值，我不打算谈论面向值编程了，
I'm just going to talk about functions because I don't know if you ever looked at code before people don't know how to write functions it's kind of scary functions are I've seen a lot of bad code in my years so
我只打算谈论函数。因为我不知道你们有没有看过以前的代码，人们根本不知道怎么写函数，这有点吓人。函数是……这些年我见过很多糟糕的代码，所以……
correct me if I'm wrong, but the title of your talk is Value-Oriented Programming. The title of my talk is Value-Oriented Programming Part 1, So You Want to Write a Function. So it's actually a talk about functions. In the world of value-oriented programming. Speaking of talk titles, I need to change my talk title and description
如果我没记错的话，你的演讲标题是《面向值的编程》。而我的演讲标题是《面向值的编程（第一部分）：你想要编写一个函数》。所以这其实是一个关于函数的演讲，在面向值的编程世界里。说到演讲标题，我需要更改我的演讲标题和简介
because I'm now doing a different talk at C++, Norah. Consider this your formal notice, Connor. All right. I will update your talk title. So I guess we don't need to give away the whole talk. And by we, I mean you, because i'm not the one giving the talk but uh why don't people know how to write functions i mean why that's a good question that's a separate question i have an answer for but but what you really what you're what you think you use certain words but that's not what you
因为我现在要在 C++ 上做一场不同的演讲，诺拉。请把它当作你的正式通知，康纳。好的。我会更新你的演讲标题。我想我们不需要把整场演讲的内容都剧透完。我说的“我们”是指你，因为不是我在做这个演讲。但是，为什么人们不知道怎么写函数呢？我的意思是，为什么……这是个好问题，我对此有别的答案，不过，你真正想问的、你以为你用了某些词但其实你并不是那个意思
meant to ask what you were asking is why do I think people don't know how to write functions? Well, you just said people don't know how to write functions. Right. Do you think people know how to write functions? Have you looked at code? How much bad code have you seen in your life? You're just a young guy. Definitely not as much as you.
你想问的其实是“为什么我认为人们不知道怎么写函数？”好吧，你刚才不就说人们不知道怎么写函数吗？对啊。你觉得人们知道怎么写函数吗？你看看代码？你这辈子见过多少烂代码？你只是个年轻人。绝对没有我见过的多。
Yeah. What? That's what? You make it sound like I wrote bad code. No, I've just seen a lot of code in my life yeah i'm guessing you've done a lot more code review yeah so most code is bad that is just it doesn't matter where i've worked most code is bad um and one of the it turns out that one of the things is just i asked this question the other day what is the fundamental building block of programming?
对啊。什么？什么意思？听起来好像我在写烂代码似的。不，我只是这辈子见过很多代码，对，我猜你做过的代码审查要多得多，对。所以大多数代码都是烂的，这就是事实，不管我在哪里工作过，大多数代码都是烂的。嗯，其中一个……原来其中一个原因就在于，我前几天问了这个问题：编程的基本构建模块是什么？
And, you know, you might say classes. Classes are like objects. I mean, it depends on who you ask. Well, the real answer is functions. Functions is the real answer. Not much happens without functions. Classes are just like complicated parameters to functions so so so functions are the real building block and they don't get used very well um you know how many you know you find
然后，你知道的，你可能会说是类。类就像对象。我的意思是，这取决于你问谁。好吧，真正的答案是函数。函数才是真正的答案。没有函数，很多事情都无法运转。类只是函数的复杂参数而已。所以，所以，所以函数才是真正的构建模块，但它们没有被很好地利用。嗯，你知道有多少……你发现
functions that are a million lines long um functions that uh just you know modify their input parameters instead of taking you know but now the real question you asked, though, is why are functions so bad or whatever you asked. And was this even the last time I was talking to you? Yeah, the last time I was on this without Bryce, but there was Ben and I, right? Yep, yep. I did the lightning talk on complecting
函数长达数百万行……有些函数……只是，你知道的，修改它们的输入参数，而不是采用，你知道的……不过现在你问的真正问题是，为什么函数这么糟糕，或者不管你问了什么。这甚至是我上次跟你说话的时候吗？对，上次我上这个节目时没有布莱斯，但有本和我，对吧？对，对。我做了一个关于交织的闪电演讲
complecting oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that is why and this is to this day this is my my it's my favorite talk even though it's like a five minute lightning talk um and it's not even that the talk's good it's that the idea in my head is good um uh complecting made easy every step of the way when we're coding the easy thing to do makes your code worse right when i need to change you know like you're sitting down you've got a task to do it's either fix a bug or add a feature you know like that's typically what you're doing right it's like oh i gotta go in here and change code. And so what you do is add an if statement wherever you need to add that if statement and like do some stuff.
交织，哦对，对，对，那就是为什么，而且直到今天，这依然是我的，我的，我最喜欢的演讲，尽管它只是一个五分钟的闪电演讲。而且甚至不是因为演讲本身有多好，而是因为我脑海中的那个概念很好。嗯……让交织变得简单。在我们编程的每一步，做简单的事情会让你的代码变得更糟，对吧？当我需要修改，你知道的，就像你坐下来，你有一个任务要做，要么是修复一个bug，要么是添加一个功能，你知道的，这通常就是你在做的事情，对吧？就像，哦，我得去这里修改代码。
And it's like, oh, this is going to fix that problem and blah, blah, blah, blah. And you just add some code just right in the middle of this function. You're probably in the wrong function because, but you went to this function because that's the code you knew. You didn't know the other code over there very well.
然后你就会觉得，哦，这能解决那个问题，巴拉巴拉巴拉。你就在这个函数的正中间加了一些代码。你可能进错函数了，但你之所以来到这个函数，是因为那是你熟悉的代码。你对旁边那段代码并不太熟悉。
So you started here with the code that you already knew. You're like, oh, I could fix this from here. If I just do this, I call this other function, it gives me the wrong answer, but if I add 0.5, then it's the right answer. So I'll add 0.5 or whatever, which literally happened today. Because I do computer vision stuff,
所以你从已经熟悉的这段代码开始。你会想，哦，我可以从这里修复它。如果我只这样做，我调用另一个函数，它给我的答案是错的，但如果我加上 0.5，那就是对的答案。所以我加上 0.5 或者别的什么，而这今天刚发生过。因为我做计算机视觉方面的工作，
and the answer's coming back, it's off by half a pixel because people don't agree what, like is zero zero the top corner of the first pixel or is zero zero the middle of the first pixel? Right? It's two different coordinate systems. So you're off by half a pixel a lot. So it's just like,
结果返回时，它偏离了半个像素，因为大家对坐标起点没有统一意见，比如零零是第一个像素的左上角，还是零零是第一个像素的正中间？对吧？这是两套不同的坐标系。所以你经常会偏离半个像素。所以它就像是，
well, if I just add 0.5 right here, it's going to fix my problem. Well, it's like, that's not the right place to add 0.5, but it's the if I just add 0.5 right here, it's going to fix my problem. Well, it's like, that's not the right place to add 0.5. But it's the easiest place to add 0.5. So you just do the easiest thing. And then it's like, should I add a new function for this? Well, that's harder than just writing the code in this current spot I'm at, right?
嗯，如果我在这里加上 0.5，就能解决我的问题。好吧，这就好比，这不是加 0.5 的正确地方，但如果我在这里加上 0.5，就能解决我的问题。好吧，这就好比，这不是加 0.5 的正确地方。但这是加 0.5 最简单的地方。所以你就做了最简单的事情。然后就会想，我应该为此添加一个新函数吗？好吧，这比直接在我当前的位置写代码要难，对吧？
Should I put this code in this class here? Or should I put it in a separate class? Or should I just put it in a separate, it's just a free function that should be somewhere. And then if I tell someone, oh, make that a free function. It doesn't have to be a member of the class. They're like, well, where do I put it?
我应该把这段代码放在这里的这个类里吗？还是应该把它放在一个单独的类里？或者我应该把它放在一个独立的、只是某个地方的自由函数里？然后，如果我告诉别人，哦，把那个做成一个自由函数。它不必是类的成员。他们就会问，那我把它放在哪里？
What CPP file do I put it in? What header do I put it in? And it's like, well, make a new header. Make a new CPP file. It's like, oh, okay. But that's hard. I mean, it's not hard, but it's harder than not doing it
我把它放在哪个 CPP 文件里？我把它放在哪个头文件里？然后就会觉得，好吧，做一个新头文件。做一个新 CPP 文件。感觉就像，哦，好吧。但这很难。我的意思是，这倒不难，但比不做要难
every step of the way these these little things it's easier to change an existing class than to like refactor it or separate it or whatever now maybe you always do the right thing maybe you know you're a good programmer and you're like why why would anyone just do that? You would, of course you would refactor when it needs to be refactored. Or of course you would write a new CBB file, a new header when, when it's a free function that, you know, is only partially associated with this class and it shouldn't be in the same header. But no one does that. Everyone just puts it wherever is easiest. And so many things we do are like that. So why is code bad? Because complecting is easy. It's the easy path. And good code is the hard path. That is my biggest insight of my life.
每一步都是如此，这些小事情：修改一个现有的类，比重构它、拆分它或者做别的什么要容易。现在，也许你总是做正确的事情，也许你知道，你是个优秀的程序员，你会想：为什么会有人只做那种事？你会的，当需要重构时你当然会去重构。或者，当这是一个自由函数、它只是部分关联到这个类而且不应该放在同一个头文件里时，你当然会编写一个新的 CPP 文件和一个新的头文件。但没有人这么做。每个人都把它放在最简单的地方。我们做的很多事情都是这样的。那么，为什么代码很烂？因为交织很简单。这是条简单的路，而好代码是艰难的路。这是我一生中最大的感悟。
So here's a super specific question in response to that very high level wisdom. I remember at one point in my first job coding in C++ where I had this class and I had basically a function in that class that was only using a single member. Maybe there was five or six members, but everything else was passed in as a parameter. And if you've read, I'm sure many people in the C++ community have either read Scott Myers' books. And I think also there was an article on Dr. Dobbs, which is like way before my time. Do you want the link? I have slides with the article. It's encapsulation. Free functions improves encapsulation or whatever it's called.
那么针对这个非常高层次的智慧，这里有一个非常具体的问题。我记得在我第一份用 C++ 编程的工作中，有一次我有一个类，我基本上在这个类里写了一个只使用了一个成员变量的函数。也许有五六个成员，但其他所有东西都是作为参数传入的。如果你读过——我相信 C++ 社区的很多人要么读过斯科特·迈尔斯（Scott Myers）的书，我想还有 Dr. Dobbs 上的一篇文章，那远在我入行之前。你想看链接吗？我的幻题里有那篇文章。讲的是封装。自由函数可以改善封装，或者不管它叫什么名字。
Right. Yeah, exactly. And that article is translated into one of the points in one of Scott's books, but it's basically gives you this hierarchy of sort of the four levels that you should prefer and you should always prefer non-member, non-friend functions if possible. And I remember writing this code initially and then was reading Scott's book at the same time. And I realized that, oh,
对。是的，没错。那篇文章被转化成了斯科特某本书中的一个观点，它基本上为你给出了一个分层，即你应该偏爱的那四级关系，如果可能的话，你应该始终偏爱非成员、非友元函数。我记得最初写这段代码时，我同时在读斯科特书，我意识到，哦，
this only, you know, relies on the ID, which was just an integer. Clearly I can move this outside and just pass the idea and then poof, you're done. But I was so conflicted at the time of doing this because, um, it was like the, it was like a calculating something from some information, and you were passing in the table and all this stuff, and the ID was... It doesn't really matter, but the function went with the class. They were bundled together.
这个只（你知道的）依赖于 ID，而它只是一个整数。显然我可以把它移到外面，只把 ID 传进去，然后——砰——就完成了。但在当时这样做时我内心非常纠缠，因为……这就像是从某些信息中计算出某些东西，你要传入表格和所有这些东西，而 ID 是……其实没关系，但这个函数是和类绑定在一起的。它们被捆绑在一起。
And when you're writing this class, based on how most C++ IDEs work, you go write the class, you go dot, poof, and it gives you the options to select from. And as soon as you move that outside, even if it's in a namespace, we don't have uniform function call syntax, and most IDEs aren't going to recommend you. I have heard that in like CLion for certain algorithms, it does have some amount of recommending of like, oh, you might be able to use this free function. But I've always been torn because I know specifically that some other languages, like they specifically lean towards
而当你编写这个类时，根据大多数 C++ IDE 的工作方式，你编写这个类，输入点（dot），砰，它就会给你提供可供选择的选项。一旦你把它移到外面，即使它在一个命名空间里，我们也没有统一函数调用语法（UFCS），而且大多数 IDE 也不会推荐它。我听说在 CLion 里针对某些算法，它确实有一定程度的推荐功能，比如，哦，你也许可以使用这个自由函数。但我一直很纠缠，因为我清楚地知道其他一些语言，它们明确倾向于
that design of like the friendliness of member functions and just being able to go dot and have autocomplete. And even though I completely agree with the article and Scott's point that, you know, that's how encapsulation, that's what it's designed for. I've always been like slightly torn just about the ergonomic, like, you know, the, the experience of programming and having member functions automatically. And like a part of me thinks that the answer is that, well, we just, if we had something like you've UFCs and IDEs were designed, it would be the same experience, but like unified function call syntax uniform um but yeah we don't we don't have unicorn unicorn yeah it should be called unicorn because we're probably never going to get it in c plus um that's this is before your time in the committee connor but that that's
这种设计，比如成员函数的友好性，只需输入点就能自动补全。尽管我完全赞同这篇文章和斯科特的观点，即这就是封装，这就是它的设计目的，但我一直对这种人体工程学、编程体验以及自动获得成员函数这件事感到有些纠缠。我有一部分想法是，答案在于，如果我们有类似 UFCS 的东西，并且 IDE 也是为此设计的，体验就会是一样的，也就是统一函数调用语法、统一……不过，是的，我们没有“独角兽（unicorn）”，我们没有独角兽，对，它应该被称为独角兽，因为我们在 C++ 里可能永远也得不到它……这是在你进委员会之前的事，康纳，但那
exactly the joke oh is it yeah it's it's not it's not a new joke it's uh it's not the first thing that's been called a unicorn either. There's other unicorn. Like unicorn initialization. I wasn't going to say it, but yeah. But anyways, interested to get your thoughts. So, yes, there is a nice ergonomics with member functions, right? But long-term, it's long-term detrimental to your code base, basically.
完全就是个笑话。哦，是吗？对，这不是，这不是一个新笑话，它……它也不是第一个被称为“独角兽”的东西。还有其他独角兽。比如独角兽初始化。我本来不想说的，但对。不过无论如何，很有兴趣听听你的想法。所以，是的，成员函数确实有一种很好的交互体验，对吧？但从长远来看，它基本上会对你的代码库造成长期的损害。
That's the problem, right? Like, how many things can you do with a string? How many functions can you write with string? Like, infinite number of functions you could write with a string, right? They can't all be member functions. So at some point, you got to draw a line and say, this is not important to be, you know, because if it really is, like, the first set of rules are just like, well, do you need
这就是问题所在，对吧？比如，你能对一个字符串做多少事情？你能用字符串写多少函数？比如，你可以用字符串写无限数量的函数，对吧？它们不可能全都是成员函数。所以在某个时刻，你必须划一条线，说：这个不重要，你知道的，因为如果它真的很重要的话，比如第一组规则只是说，好吧，你需要吗
the internal member variables? Like, if you don't need them, that's a good sign it doesn't need to be a member function, right? But it's not the only thing. As an example, and like on the committee, I argue this sometimes. Back in the day when we used to have meetings in person, I remember arguing this. Like string has 200 member functions or something. It's terrible. It's a terrible class. And most of them could have been algorithms because they don't have to just work on strings. They can work on vectors and other things, right?
内部成员变量？比方说，如果你不需要它们，这就是一个好迹象，说明它不需要是一个成员函数，对吧？但这并不是唯一的事情。举个例子，在委员会里，我有时会争论这个。过去我们还在进行面谈开会的时候，我记得我曾争论过这个。比如 string 有 200 个左右的成员函数。这太糟糕了。这是一个糟糕的类。而且它们大部分本可以写成算法，因为它们不必仅仅适用于 string。它们也可以适用于 vector 以及其他东西，对吧？
And then we introduced starts with, I think, is one of the recent functions we added to string, right? It's a member function. And I argued that it should be a member function. But that's because the ergonomics are so bad when it's not because if you have a function it's called starts with and it takes two strings you're like oh which one's like the needle which one's the haystack right and and it's hard but if it's you know uh haystack dot starts with needle no one is confused about about what that function does.
然后我们引入了 starts_with，我想，这是我们最近添加到 string 的函数之一，对吧？它是一个成员函数。我当时争论过它应该是一个成员函数。但那是因为当它不是成员函数时，其人体工程学（使用体验）太糟糕了，因为如果你有一个函数叫 starts_with 并且它接收两个字符串，你就会想：哦，哪个是 needle（要找的子串），哪个是 haystack（被查找的字符串），对吧？这很难辨别。但如果是，你知道的，呃，haystack.starts_with(needle)，没有人会搞混那个函数是做什么的。
Clearly, we just need infix binary function. Yeah, that could be the answer too, right? That's what Connor is thinking. But either way, for every rule out there, there's going to be exceptions, things to balance out. The answer in C++ is always, it depends. But the more member functions, I like to say that classes are made of Velcro. Classes are made of Velcro.
显然，我们只需要中缀二元函数。是的，那也可能是答案，对吧？这就是 Connor 想法。但无论如何，对于外面的每一条规则，都会有例外，有需要权衡的地方。C++ 中的答案永远是“这取决于具体情况”。但成员函数越多——我喜欢说类是由魔术贴制成的。类是由魔术贴制成的。
You continually attach more things to the class. And then you start attaching functions to the class. You're like, okay, here's this thing that goes along with the class. We'll attach it. And then you attach another function. And then somewhere down the road, you're like, oh, this function doesn't really work unless I have this other thing. Oh, to fix this, I'm going to add another member variable to the class.
你会不断地给类贴上更多的东西。然后你开始把函数附加到类上。你会想：好吧，这是和这个类配套的东西，我们把它贴上去。然后你又附加了另一个函数。再往后，你会想：哦，除非我有这个别的东西，否则这个函数其实无法正常工作。哦，为了解决这个问题，我要在类里加一个新的成员变量。
Right? And now your class has gotten bigger. You didn't just add new functions to it. You added new, you you know stuff in your class and a class becomes this nexus point of entanglement where everything goes through this class right if you change one function or one member variable this class you might have broken all these functions right because it's all you know they can all touch the internals and you've got like 200 member functions you have to worry about breaking when you change something and you that's you've you've entangled classes are
对吧？现在你的类变得更大了。你不仅仅给它添加了新函数，你还在类里添加了新东西，类变成了纠缠的交汇点，所有东西都通过这个类，对吧？如果你更改了这个类的某个函数或某个成员变量，你可能就会破坏所有这些函数，因为它们全都可以访问内部实现，当你修改某样东西时，你得担心会破坏大约 200 个成员函数，这就是——如果你不小心的的话，类就是纠缠点。
points of entanglement unless you're careful about it so that's yeah that's how that's the other way you complex things is by someone. I had someone. I can't give away what I, my, my, my interview questions, but I had a question about, you know, two points and some function you could do on some points. Tony, it's not like you're on a popular podcast. You can give away your interview secrets. Basically it's tune in next week to hear what Tony's interview question podcast. Yeah, yeah. You can give away your interview secrets. Basically, tune in next week
除非你小心翼翼，否则类就是纠缠的焦点。所以，是的，这就是使事情变得复杂的另一种方式。我曾遇到过一个人。我不能透露我的面试题是什么，但我有一个关于两个点以及你对某些点可以执行的某种函数的问题。托尼，你又不是上什么热门播客，你可以透露你的面试秘密的。基本上就是：下周收听，听听托尼的面试题是什么播客。对，对。你可以透露你的面试秘密。基本上，下周收听
to hear what Tony's interview question is. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来听听托尼的面试题是什么。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。